A rooster...cat?
And Ronald orders a number three.
It's episode 41 of IMG!
City life.
Oh hi.
And here's a necktie that's formal
and manly, though, of course,
I prefer one piece
cat faces. Too much coverage?
Well, try on one of these
or just wear a slice of bread on your face. It's
almost as good as squishing it up against bars.
Hayashi Natsumi takes photos of herself relaxing
mid-jump.
Tug on a blowhole
with this whale tissue holder and the
movie poster for The Dark Knight Rises
contains an awesome
hidden bat shape,
but some people see a jumping unicorn.
Here kid, have a sparkler.
I mean, say cheese.
Doh. The baby's okay,
so take your dog for a walk
skate and then put a price sticker on Moby
Dick just right
and you get...
Wow, okay, look, let's just get some knowledge.
In Canada, postal codes are alphanumeric.
And in British Columbia
you can visit V4G1N4.
Alright, let's be more mature.
Every year during the wet season, Lake Titicaca
overflows into lake Poopó, which in
turn overflows into Salar de Uyuni,
the world's largest salt bed.
It is so big
it contains 70 percent of our world's lithium reserves
and it's so flat that orbiting
satellites use it
to determine the steadiness of their altitudes.
When it rains,
Salar de Uyuni becomes the world's
largest mirror.
But if that's too much water for you,
you don't have to travel very far to get to
Antofagasta Region of the Atacama
Desert, the driest
place on Earth. On average,
the entire desert only receives one
millimeter of rain each year. And some
weather stations out there have yet
in human history to have recorded
rainfall. In fact, between 1570
and 1971 it is estimated that no significant water
fell there at all.
It's so near sterile
NASA uses the region to test Mars rovers
and in some areas of the desert
those rovers found not a single trace
of life.
On Facebook.com/VsauceGaming
Panagiotis showed that with the right
clouds the Sun
could become a smiley face.
He also showed off an inquisitive
beard and Tim Ryan helped out.
Okay.
I'll go left and then I'll go... wait.
I'm just gonna lay around with some chicks.
And as always,
thanks for watching.